[Music]
foreign
view a first look of course at what is
on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with Andrew
Pierce consultant editor of the Daily
Mail and Kevin McGuire associate editor
of the Daily Mirror and lovely to see
both of you so front pages let's take a
look shall we the Metro leads with the
problems that the manston Immigration
Center and a man trying to rescue his
nephew from there after spotting him on
the front of the paper last night on the
same issue the eye claims an exclusive
with news that a coach load of manston
residents were dumped on a street at
Victoria Station by mistake that is also
the lead story for the guardian home
office abandoned monster no Asylum
Seekers they say here's the Daily
Express reporting that the Home
Secretary swella bravman is lining up
three more countries after Rwanda to
send migrants for processing
The Daily Mail leads with new research
that claims that one in every six people
now living in England and Wales was born
overseas
the times reporting that the chancellor
is planning a tax grab
on energy Giants to help balance the
nation's finances
the financial times leads with the
latest rise in U.S interest rates with
the news that there are more increases
to come in the battle against inflation
decision here of course tomorrow at noon
while the telegraph says the bank of
England may be about to do the same well
the star urges viewers to keep voting
for Matt Hancock on I'm a celebrity to
make sure he is forced to do every or
very unpleasant Bush Tucker trials that
there are
Coco anyway and the Sun goes with what
it calls a cover-up at the BBC over a
Strictly Come Dancing contestants on
screen tumble
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see it on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch our guests so let's go to Andrew
Pierce consultant editor at the mail and
uh Kevin McGuire associate editor at the
mirror welcome to both of you
um Andrew you kicker kick us off then um
the I and the guardian both reporting
that the home office abandoned people
held at this manston Asylum processing
center in central London and to be fair
the home office has said tonight it will
not comment but uh your thoughts on this
well it's a metaphor really for
everything that's going wrong with the
Asylum Refugee system it's chaos uh we
know it's chaos it's been chaos for a
long time the processing is taking too
long it's taking years instead of uh
weeks and months uh and now this is a
complete shambles this is a coach load
of uh refugees Asylum seeks whatever you
want to call them from Manson being
moved out being evacuated is the
expression used uh and they're coming
into London and for some reason the
coach driver either
did it off his own back or was got the
wrong instructions literally dump them
outside Victoria railway station and um
the public uh and um police passing
police officers had to intervene to sort
it out it's it's terrible it's
embarrassing uh look I mean I I think
the government has to take a hard line
on these migrants crossing the channel
Kevin and I will always disagree on this
but this is but this is just appalling
and as I say it is a metaphor for
everything that is going wrong uh in
Dover in Kent uh with the system it's
they've just got to get a grip yes and
local Council leaders say they can't
cope Kevin for committee chairs in the
House of Commons are asking for you know
for clarification we've heard tonight
from Robert genre immigration Minister
that they're facing a judicial review on
the conditions there at the manston
processing center you know are the
wheels falling off or was it ever thus
on this issue
it was that's the point uh Kia storm of
the labor leader was making at Prime
Minister's questions where he certainly
got the better of Rishi sunak the new
prime minister and he said look you've
been in power for 12 years all these
problems are on your watch and this
coach which there were 11 people on
according to the guardian some just in
in flip-flops it's it's a broken system
it just isn't working why isn't it
working it's not just the pressure of
the number of people going there was a
backlog building in the processing of
claims before that and yeah the system
isn't isn't working and it should work
and instead of screaming as well
Brotherman doesn't shout Invasion to try
and divert attention away from her
failings in that job I think you've got
it you've got to focus you want somebody
who can somehow make it work and Robert
the immigration Minister uh seems to be
a positioning himself to take over from
Brotherman as as Home Secretary and I do
wonder how long she has has got left
actually
well yeah I think you and other people
have have thought that but um swella
bravman on the front page of the Daily
Express
um it does appear that the only tool in
the box is deterrent
um this report says that she's eyeing up
three more countries Beyond Rwanda
um it's only a short paragraph there but
it suggests Paraguay Peru and Belize are
on the cards now you know will this
policy ever work Andrew and is the right
decision to ship people out
they got the nationality and borders
bill that's the whole idea of that which
labor opposed of course was to process
applications overseas in places like
Rwanda uh but it's been it's been
blocked at every turn by human rights
lawyers uh exploiting the uh human
rights legislation brought in by the
Blair government and this is going to
continue and that's what sunap is
getting uh the Prime Minister was
getting great cross about in the chamber
today uh it is being frustrated at every
turn it is costing tens of millions of
pounds and you do wonder if if they get
one plane to Rwanda Anna the thought is
in the home office and in number 10 that
will finally act as a deterrent because
those are those those refugees or
economic migrants or some of them
undoubtedly are in my view one across
the channel they think they're then
going to be Center Rwanda but they've
got to get one playing off the ground
and they haven't managed it yet so
whether they're going to be any more
successful with Peru uh uh and Belize
what what's the other one where was the
other one Paraguay who knows well we
heard did we not from kirstama today
secure
um and the retort from richest United
we're on the same pledge the opposition
has a blank page you can't attack a plan
if you don't have a plan what is a plan
of anybody has anybody got a plan to fix
this Kevin
yeah labor did quickly put out a plan
and it will speed up uh um the the
process and also make international
agreements so people can go back to the
countries from which they came uh Andrew
talks about people being blocked it's
because the government isn't following
the law and isn't respecting rights both
domestically and those we sign up to
internationally that's why people
haven't gone to Rwanda which I think is
a very squalid 140 million pound deal by
the government but again you see
bravaman she said she dreams of getting
somebody on a plane or a one that she
hasn't got anybody on a plane to Rwanda
she might never get somebody on a plate
or Rwanda but there she's now spinning
to the express three more countries so
is she going to appear to be acting and
as if she's doing something to resolve
the issue when she is not and she's held
responsible for a lot of the problems
recently Roger Gale who is the local MP
for manston conservative sir Roger Gale
said manston used to work perfectly well
until she went to the home office and
then she took decisions on not to move
people out and it created Created
problems no it come back towards stalma
said they've had 12 years they haven't
got it right their rhetoric is
increasing the talk and then invasion is
absolutely vile and there is no there is
no Invasion and the number of people
coming to Britain is relatively small
compared to other countries around the
world but if you've got a deal that you
need to processing them quickly you need
a legal routine for those who are
entitled to come and most people who get
here over the channel are found a hat of
legal claims to stay here and I granted
leave to stay once their claims are
processed and then those that are judged
not to be a a entitled to stay then you
need a system to repatriate them that's
all you need it's going to be harder now
in Europe because of brexit because
we're now par no longer part the Dublin
regulation whereby you could send people
to the country they came to yours from
and I'd reiterate under the 1951 U.N
Refugee convention people are entitled
to travel through other countries to
seek asylum in the country they choose
as their destination well
can we just say Kevin says not it's not
you know not not so many people 40 000
already it'll be fifty thousand sixty
thousand by the end of the year that's a
small town every year it's doubling
every year and the re and Kevin says oh
labor will speed up the application
process the the processing system well
that's what the Tories are trying to do
and it's not working and partly it's not
working because there are so many
appeals by the human rights Lobby uh
lawyers on legal aid blocking the
process at every single turn that's
what's causing part of the backlog and
and if you're ever accused of anything
and do you get a loyal soon you've got a
Lobby
you're going to try and enforce your
legal rights
are coming from Albania there's no war
in Albania Kevin there's no persecution
in Albania the coming here is economic
migrants and they should be kicked out
immediately did you hear the prime
minister of Albanian read the prime
minister of Albania today instead in the
UK government
like you a shouty act and doing it make
an agree with the French have an
agreement without being in the Germans
have not in agreement with Albania has
the UK got an agreement with Albania no
try and negotiate one you will solve the
problem because we're a soft touch okay
you know I don't want to come to Britain
and the head of the head of the head of
them
the head of the Border Force who was
dealing with this said last week they
typically come stay for six to 12 months
and then go home yes
they have worked unofficially now
there's a million plus vacancies a
record number of vacancies in the UK
economy why don't we try and match them
because people come here
the Albanian uh leader who said
targeting albanians as some shamefully
did when fighting for brexit as the
cause of Britain's crime and Border
problems makes for easy rhetoric but
ignores hard facts meanwhile uh Robert
genre can his interview with us tonight
um suggested that uh you know where does
public opinion sit on this he said why
many people be asking why is the UK
spending millions of pounds to house
young men coming from a safe country uh
while Craig McKinley Tory MP as you'll
know a wand of a Resurgence uh to a ukip
style party if his uh party the Tories
don't get a grip on this which takes us
Andrew to the Daily Mail and feeds into
that public opinion that one in six of
us are now born overseas now how will
that sit with the people in this country
well I think uh look I mean it's it's
how it's changing this is this is in the
new census this is a dramatic change in
10 years and a lot of them they're
saying are coming from Romania that's
that's both the biggest increase it
slowed down the increase after brexit
thank God uh but um we are to the
country is changing dramatically and a
lot of this started of course with labor
back under the Blair government
encouraging Mass immigration from
Eastern Europe and other countries in
the EU brought in uh uh transitional
limits labor didn't and uh and and
within two years there was a million
people that arrived from Eastern Europe
as opposed to the 15 or 20 000 that was
predicted by the Blair government they
did it deliberately
that it covers England and Wales and we
are now a more vibrant diverse country
and a better country I would say than
when I was a kid in the 70s and 80s in
uh multiculturalism has worked for
Britain it is very good and very
positive we've got to see the whole
debate in that light instead of it
continually being regarded as a problem
and there is there is something terribly
wrong with the way Britain has changed
it's not Britain's changed for the
better largely I would say sorry for
Interruption you've got loads to pack
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Andrew
Pierce and Kevin McGuire welcome back to
both of you
um so the financial times reporting on
the U.S federal reserve their Central
Bank putting up interest rates once
again by another 0.75 Point increase
that's the fourth consecutive time
they've done that which takes us to what
might happen here in the UK uh front
page of the Daily Telegraph Bank set for
the biggest rate rise Andrew since black
Wednesday the paper tells us
yeah thinking it will be like America
0.75 that will take us up to three
percent
um still below America but um it's it's
it's the bag trying to curb inflation
which we know is now in double figures
10.1 uh but this is going to hurt people
a lot in their mortgages if you save us
if you're that will help a lot of
pensioners who've got savings they will
start to see a proper interest rate
return on their savings but if you have
got a mortgage your credit card all
these costs are going to go up and the
problem I think for the for the
government is this even though interest
rates are going up across the world
everywhere the higher in America than
they are here even if we put them up
tomorrow people will blame I think the
truss mini budget traceonomics uh so the
Tories will have to own some of this and
it's going to be but issue sooner to try
to somehow uh divert the blame because
they've got to take some of the blame
because the Market's worth so spooked by
what the uh the trust budget was due
doing because they didn't try to take
the markets with them they didn't
explain where the uh the money was going
to come from and um we saw what happened
in the guilts market Kevin and I don't
really understand the guilts market but
we know the yields were down or where
they are but anyway they went the wrong
way and that caused problems for
interest rates yeah I know it was
confusing for for many of us was it not
um the telegraph elsewhere actually
suggesting that the potentially biggest
rate rise in 30 years or three decades
uh might not push up fixed rate mortgage
costs because deals had already been
overpriced in the wake of the trust
quote many budget so we'll see what
happens with that but I do want a quick
word on
um vote Coco No I don't get that oh Coco
the clown he's the clown am I moving
slowly towards the story Kevin help me
out
yeah and Matt Hancock the star called
him a coke with the clown and they want
uh it's readers launched a campaign to
keep on getting them to do every trial
so as they say keep on kicking him in
the uh the ballots until he uh until
he's voted voted out eventually
interestingly though the public will get
a get a vote in this didn't in the uh
Tory leadership uh uh imposition that's
twice they've imposed Liz trust and
something like that I vote maybe I'm a
celebrity is the way that the Tory party
could choose its leaders in the future
could send them all into the jungle then
we'd get a vote at home
is a disgrace being in there you know
it's really appalling and uh it's being
attacked by the covid families who were
affected or lost loved ones and and you
know the the early stages of the covert
inquiry have just begun did he not
realize the optic of this it just looks
terrible boy it's the absolute end of
that I've got political career and
deservedly so it's appalling It's a UK
governing conservative party falling
apart that's what we're with it's not
that getting it's not about that it's
just about what he is
the economy
thank you both very much indeed